I'm loathe to ask this but perverse
curiosity overcomes me what about our
own sad union well this is one of the
things that any time I go into a deep
space I take a look at and even though
we see like hopeful rays of light you
know in our in our part of the world I'm
also seeing the other side and since on
occasion I'm able to tune in to a much
deeper level like a more esoteric level
of a scene I'm aware that we have a
certain time frame and know time is kind
of running out so that unless there is a
big big switch you know to owning our
power in our spirituality in our light
that we're on the brink of disaster
and this really concerns me a lot I know
just the earthquake activity in
California has been something and I look
for more so you're not talking about
political or economic disaster you know
you're talking about something more an
act of God all that's right because it
seems that what brings people together
is when we have disasters we have a need
you know to support each other and I
would hate to see it come to that you
know to that place where we actually
have a tremendous disaster illness or
for instance like aids becomes even more
prevalent where we will have to band
together and well you know some people
feel that the undoing of the Soviet you
and can really be traced to the
Chernobyl okay I think it can everything
has a you know has a a result well now
didn't someone here at this conference
this seems to me like a recurring theme
it's the idea that things are going to
get worse before they get better because
there needs to be some kind of shock
wait
that's what I feel is is somehow you
know as long as we're comfortable we're
very complacent but when all of a sudden
our life is threatened and just our
general environment is threatened then
we you know we rise up in arms we get
you know we become very activated and
I'm just hoping that somehow we won't
have to come to that to that point
before we will all see you know we will
all see the same picture together
and do something about it do you think I
mean it's clear we're all motivated to
try and do something to try and make the
world better but what I worry about is
is there enough urgency I don't think
there is yet so unfortunately I don't
think the room we're still half asleep
yes and I feel that one of these days
mother nature may get very impatient
shake her back and we'll get it and
perhaps we need it I mean perhaps we
have to be you know done that too you
know I have to be done too before we
wake up and say okay what's important in
my life because I feel so many people
have lost sense of personal
responsibility it's having fun all the
outer things or what it you know are so
important rather than the true meaning
for their life and that is their life
script and to find out who they are and
how they can get there and how they can
contribute so people have been
distracted by the surface very much so
that's one of the things that I try to
push like what's you know what is your
illness teaching you what is it trying
to tell you how can you get past it and
once you get past it once you get rid of
the blocks then the real stuff that
you're here to do or inspired to do will
come out and that's exactly what
happened to me
before that it was I feel powerless so
because you had this as a direct
experience Gary great conviction to
speak to people that's right that it's
possible not all illnesses
you know are connected with with a
spiritual and spiritual emergency but a
lot of them are it's the way that our
soul somehow gets our attention through
pain through distorting the physical all
right until we s until we ask enough
questions and say what's going on if
we're ready to hear it's there it's all
there
well maybe we could make a hopeful
metaphor and expand that to the global
level yes that's what I hope for and say
you know the earth is trying to get our
attention I mean surely all of your
nature trying to by trying I was I have
you know in my intuitive state tuned in
to mother nature because you can tune
into any any you know any form any
system and what of what she has said to
me is that I'm saying I'm very very sad
it's almost like you know I'm being
destroyed being consumed in some very
negative ways and that's not my function
my function is to provide a wonderful
living space for us to grow in so
generally are you hopeful about human
fate Georgie I am I have a lot of faith
in individuals I really do because I
feel that once we wake up like you know
we're movers and we do things so I think
the trick is how do you wake more people
up all at once so the real situation is
that the real struggle to save the
planet has not yet begun I don't think
so we're still doing we're still
drifting we still haven't gotten that at
the point that we are in a tremendous
crisis
and once we get everybody awakened to
that and focused this is exactly what I
think that it's going to take some
terrible terrible things you know HG
Wells said history is a race between
education and catastrophe and it looks
to me like it's gonna be a photo finish
I think it will be yeah but I still have
faith that somehow you know we're
heartful enough and loving enough and
caring enough to see the to see the real
picture that there must be a purpose in
in the human adventure it isn't just it
isn't just an adventure no it is but the
goal is enlightenment you see and I'm
not I'm not sure that we've gotten that
message that clearly it that clearly
defined well it's hard to tell whether
we're collectively moving toward some
kind of global enlightenment or we're
simply moving towards the ruination of
everything well the whole thing is
attitude it depends upon how we feel
what we do what we think in the next few
years as to what the outcome will be
where you say attitude I would say it's
language language you can't live a
future you can't describe
so we have to delay the heart and the
the mine has to have a target that it
understands and I see
I think as yet we have not gotten that
target every year no little pockets of
people here and there of course have it
but no general
[Music]